- [Voiceover] Hey, this
is Kim from Khan Academy.
I am the History Fellow here,
and I am here with Emily.
- [Voiceover] Hi, I'm the Biology Fellow.
- [Voiceover] So, Emily and I are here
talking about Darwinism.
I'm interested in Darwinism,
because in the late 19th century,
usually called the Gilded Age,
there is a very prominent interpretation
of Darwinism that is
called, Social Darwinism.
Social Darwinism wasn't so
much an actual form of biology,
as it was, kind of a misinterpretation
of how natural selection and
the theory of evolution worked,
that was used to justify or explain
a lot of the social inequalities
of this time period.
The way people often thought about it
was that white Anglo-Saxon people,
so Europeans, Northern Europeans,
were kind of the most evolved.
This is our timeline of evolution,
from least evolved to most evolved,
and people like African Americans,
or Asians, or Native Americans,
or even Eastern Europeans,
were less evolved.
That they were on a scale of evolution
where they hadn't come
as far as Anglo-Saxons.
So, Emily, you're a biologist,
and I would love to get your take
on how it is that natural
selection actually works,
and how this doesn't
quite describe what was
really going on.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, definitely.
So, maybe I can speak first
to that specific graph
that you've drawn on.
I think that this is
actually a common point
of confusion when it comes to evolution,
that there's not really such a thing,
as more or less evolved in evolution.
So--
- [Voiceover] Okay, so,
this gradient really doesn't exist.
- [Voiceover] No, I mean,
there's sort of the,
I think that people
sometimes see the pictures
of like, the ape standing up,
and turning into a person,
and they think, "Oh, this
is sort of a linear path
"from one thing to another."
What you really get is different
types of organisms evolving
from a shared ancestor, and branching off.
So--
- [Voiceover] All right so--
- [Voiceover] Nobody
who's alive on Earth today
has been evolving for more or less time,
since their last common ancestor,
than anybody else.
- [Voiceover] So would you,
I'm gonna draw what I think
is how you're explaining this,
and please correct me, as I go along.
Say this is my common ancestor,
and then would there possibly
be branches like this?
- [Voiceover] Yeah, that's
a great way to draw it.
Certainly, humans are all
extremely closely related
to each other,
but we could even say this for us,
versus a dog, a bacterium.
Pretty much anything, all life on Earth,
shares a common ancestor.
That bacteria is just as
evolved as you are, actually,
in this sense of absolute time,
since those two split apart.
- [Voiceover] Right, so
from the moment that life
first appeared on Earth,
there has been so much time,
and all of us have been
evolving from that point.
Even whether you're a piece of bacteria,
piece a good word?
A bacterium?
- [Voiceover] There you go!
- [Voiceover] Excellent.
- [Voiceover] Beautiful.
(laughs)
- [Voiceover] So bacterium.
I took biology once,
or you are Albert Einstein.
You have been evolving for
precisely the same amount
of time.
- [Voiceover] Yep.
- [Voiceover] Awesome.
Okay, wow, I'm really relieved
to find that I could describe
that as well as I could.
(laughs)
- [Voiceover] You did a great job.
Beautiful.
- [Voiceover] Okay, so you've done this,
this distinction between
evolving from a common ancestor.
How is it that the actual theory
of natural selection works?
- [Voiceover] Yeah,
that's a great question.
So, natural selection,
often people talk about it
as sort of, having three key ingredients.
To see how it works, let's
imagine that we're just looking
at a population of beetles.
So picture you're beetles, to start with.
What would we need to have,
in order for these beetles,
as a group, to evolve
by natural selection?
One thing that we would need is,
we would need some
variation among the beetles.
- [Voiceover] Okay.
- [Voiceover] So, if you
have identical beetles,
you're not going to have any
that are better at surviving
or reproducing, than any others,
which is kind of a key ingredient,
for what we're gonna talk about.
- [Voiceover] Okay.
So, I've got two different beetles here.
They're slightly
different from each other.
- [Voiceover] Awesome.
You've made them different
colors, which is perfect.
We have variation,
and the next ingredient
that we're going to need,
is we're gonna need that
variation to be heritable.
We're gonna say that those beetles,
one of them is green
and one of them is blue,
and that's because of
something in their DNA.
They have differences in their DNA,
that create the variation in colors.
- [Voiceover] Okay.
Alright, so, when you say
heritable, you mean that this
is something that their
descendants could inherit?
- [Voiceover] Exactly.
That is exactly it.
So the final ingredient
is that, the differences,
these heritable differences,
need to affect how good the beetles are
at leaving offspring
in the next generation.
- [Voiceover] Alright, okay.
- [Voiceover] For example, let's say,
we would probably have
more than two beetles,
in our actual population --
- [Voiceover] Okay.
- [Voiceover] But, let's say
this population has just moved
into a new area that is very blue colored.
- [Voiceover] Okay.
- [Voiceover] So blue rocks,
blue flowers, whatever.
There's also a bunch of
birds in that environment
that really like to eat beetles.
- [Voiceover] Oh.
- [Voiceover] I'm guessing,
that if they have blue
beetles and green beetles,
that one of those is
gonna show up a lot better
against the blue
environment, than the other.
Probably a lot of our
green beetles are gonna get
picked off by birds, and
they're not gonna be able
to leave offspring, because
gosh, they kinda got ate.
(laughs)
So, when you look at the
next generation of beetles,
if we know that the
colors get passed on --
- [Voiceover] Mm-hmm.
- [Voiceover] We're gonna
probably see a bigger group of,
a bigger proportion of that group,
being made up of blue beetles,
and less being made up of green.
That is an example of
natural selection in action,
where you can see that
organisms that survive and,
specifically, reproduce better,
in a certain environment,
are going to increase in
frequency in a population.
You're gonna get more and
more of these blue guys,
less and less of the green guys.
- [Voiceover] Is there
a word you would use
to describe this, sort
of, this adaptation?
Is that the natural selection part,
as from variation, inheritable?
Like, the natural selection
is just like a good situation?
- [Voiceover] Yeah, I mean,
natural selection is really,
just the differential
survival and reproduction.
As you mentioned a great word
there, which is adaptation.
- [Voiceover] Mm-hmm.
- [Voiceover] Adaptation
is the word that biologists
often give to the process
of a population getting
better and better suited
to its environment.
You would say that the
population was adapting to being
in a blue space --
- [Voiceover] Mm-hmm.
- [Voiceover] As it gradually
started to have more and more
blue beetles, across generations.
- [Voiceover] What I find
really interesting about this,
is that it's entirely by chance, right?
More or less, you've
got a genetic mutation,
and then that mutation happens
to suit the environment
that you're in, which allows
you to thrive and your genes,
and your adaptations to
be passed on, over time.
- [Voiceover] Yes!
I mean, the variation would
have occurred randomly
to start with.
Like you say, it would've been a mutation,
it didn't happen 'cause the
beetles went to a blue place,
and said, "Gosh, I should be
blue, that would be awesome."
That was not what happened.
It was already there and it
just happened to be successful
in that environment.
If they'd gone to a green
place, well, guess what?
You would've gotten exactly
the opposite effect.
Suddenly, the green guys
would've been more successful,
more able to leave offspring,
and you would've seen
green be increasing or,
"favored by natural selection."